John: Good morning Hank, it's Wednesdaaaaaaay,
it's Pizzamas!
We've just come from the Save the Children
Gala.
Hank: I met Jennifer Garner.
J: That was weird but she seemed cool.
H: and I stood nearby Olivia Wilde.
J: It could be a Gala or a gah-lah.
H: Do you want to answer some questions that
people --
J: YES!
H: -- just sent in?
John Green, what is your opinion on lamps?
J: I am opposed to them.
H: I love lamp.
Debate over the best kind of chocolate: white,
milk, or dark.
J: I don't know that this is going to be a
debate but I actually have a very strong opinion,
so let's just do this 1 2 3.
One, two, three!
Both together: Dark!
J: Oh thank god!
Because we were about to not be brothers anymore.
H: Will there ever be dear Hank and John merch?
J: That's what the world's missing is dear
Hank and John merch.
You know what kind of merch we DO have?
Pizza John merch is available now.
H: Eeeeh.
Only for a couple more days.
J: At DFTBA.com.
Pizzamas merch, it's like suits... but mostly
T-shirts and shoelaces.
H: Actually, you know what I was wearing underneath
the whole time--
J: Ooooh!
H: during the Save the Children gala.
J: He likes to keep me close to his heart.
H: John --
J: Yeah.
H: -- Do your best impression of your favorite
dinosaur.
J: We don't know what dinosaurs sounded like.
H: [disappointed exhale]
J: It's true!
[squawk]
H: Ok.
Ok.
J: Might be.
H: I'm glad you-- at least you made a noise.
J: That was a diplodocus.
My favorite dinosaur.
But we don't know if that's what they sounded
like [retching] we don't know!
We have no way of knowing [retching] we have
no way of knowing.
[screeching]
H: maybe they just like, sounded like humans.
They were just like [babbling] Like that dog
from that thing on Tumblr.
[impersonating human dog]
J: Rosianna took away my Tumblr password,
so I don't know what's happening on Tumblr
anymore
H: [gibberish]
J: Sounds funny.
H: It's pretty funny.
J: Why did you take away my Tumblr password?
There are so many lovely things happening.
H: [gibberish]
J: Nicole's question is "What are your holiday
traditions?
H: Saying what we're thankful for.
J: Oh, our mom always puts tremendous pressure
on us
H: There is a great deal of pressure
J: To come up with like a new thing that we're
thankful for.
So if I say like I'm thankful for my kids,
Mom will always say "No no no no no, you said
that in 2011."
[Hank laughs] Then I'll have to think of something
new that I'm thankful for.
And I'm 38, you know?
That's 38 years of having to be grateful.
H: Yeah, you gotta take like individual foods.
[John laughs] Like "this year I'm thankful
for green beans!"
J: God, I'm so grateful for cranberries.
Where would we be without them as a species?
H: Yeah, right.
Yeah, exactly the same place, but where would
cranberries be?
J: They would be dead.
Like 40% of species, which we've eliminated
in the last 500 years, go team!
[Hank reluctantly high fives] Actually, no.
That was... not an appropriate high five.
H: Well, I mean 99.9% of species that have
existed no longer exist.
J: Tight, but we've--
H: Usually not so rapidly.
J: We've eliminated more in the last 400 years
than in the previous million.
H: Yeah.
Yeah, we're roughly on par with an asteroid.
J: We are killin' it...
H: Oh!
J: Literally.
Hank, can you please describe the meaning
of life from the perspective of a chicken?
H: [a startlingly accurate impression of a
chicken]
J: [giggles]
H: [continues to be good at being a chicken]
J: Hank, how did you and John meet your wives?
H: I met my wife, she lived across a, uh...
J: a desert!
[Hank laughs] A continent!
H: hallway
J: An ocean!
H: From my dorm room.
J: Alright, room service is here, we have
to go.
Hank.
H: Yes.
J: Thank you for being awesome, I like your
tie by the way.
H: You're welcome, I got it at Banana Republic.
J: DFTBA, I will see you right now and also
tomorrow.